auch in der stadt die den spitznamen
london grad trägt wird für den frieden
demonstriert und gegen russische
oligarchen briten und ukrainer seit' an
seit' unter die protestierenden haben
sich auch ein paar russinnen gemischt
yanar baku nina lebt seit 20 jahren in
london
alles was ich als kind gelernt habe war
krieg ist etwas sehr schlimmes und jetzt
plötzlich sind wir die aggressoren in
einem krieg gegen unsere nachbarn ein
land in dem wir familie und freunde
haben das ist inakzeptabel außerdem
können die leute in russland ja nicht
demonstrieren
jana schämt sich für ihre regierung und
für die britische die nur sehr zögerlich
ihre bereitschaft erklärt ukrainische
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen außerdem findet
sie london hätte sich längst von den
männern distanzieren müssen die mit
putins hilfe zu milliardären wurden und
ihr geld in die britische hauptstadt
schafften
region hat informationen herausgegeben
welche konten mit wie viel geld sie
gesperrt hat viel mehr als die usa und
die sie wollen zeigen wie strengen sie
jetzt sind aber es zeigt natürlich auch
wie sehr london das zentrum der
russischen geldwäsche ist
die briten haben fast siebenmal mehr
vermögenswerte eingefroren als die eu
wer viel hat kann viel sperren die
außenministerin lobt sich selbst
wir sind in diesen tagen an frauen dass
der front mit aktionen gegen den kreml
und vier beschleunigen sanktionen gegen
russische oligarch
doch ganz vorne dabei waren liszts und
andere konservative politikerin auch als
die ehefrau des ehemaligen
stellvertretenden russischen
finanzministers 160.000 euro
parteispende für ein abendessen bot
insgesamt zwei millionen pfund sollen
die konservativen von russischen
spendern bekommen haben seit boris
johnson premier geworden ist
auf betreiben johnsons sitzt etwa auch
evgeny lebedjew als lord lebe der von
hampton und sibirien im britischen
oberhaus
[Musik]
russisches geld durch ziel london wie
ein unsichtbares netz sagt anwalt
michael kufner und der muss es wissen
denn er berät viele reiche russen
verschiedene britische regierungen haben
die oligarchen aktiv ermutigt mit ihren
familien nach london zu ziehen ihre
kinder hier auf die schule zu schicken
englische gerichte für
rechtsstreitigkeiten oder scheidungen zu
nutzen eigentum in london zu kaufen die
britische nationalität anzunehmen all
das ist über einen langen zeitraum
geschehen wenn sie nun eine komplette
kehrtwende in dieser sache hinlegt muss
die regierung sich also zumindest ein
wenig merkwürdig fühlen
so komplett ist die kehrtwende
allerdings nicht nur 13 superreiche
stehen auf der britischen sanktionsliste
usa und eu haben deutlich mehr
oligarchen mit sanktionen belegt und
geschoren dagegen bleibt bisher der wohl
berühmteste bewohner london graz wo man
abramowitsch bei seinem fc chelsea hatte
er geld tore schießen lassen geschätzte
1,8 milliarden euro steckte in den klub
den er nun eilig verkaufen möchte und
wenn möglich auch einige seiner teuren
immobilien
vor allem im nord londoner stadtteil
high geht haben die russen sich
niedergelassen der chip beach mit haus
gehört alischer usmanow ein kandidat auf
der sanktionsliste das anwesen guten
horst dem düngemittel magnaten andrejew
es hat 25 schlafzimmer und einen
geschätzten wert von 360 millionen euro
wie der buckingham palast ist noch
größer
in unmittelbarer nachbarschaft liegt
einer der schönsten friedhöfe londons
passenderweise ist hier karl marx
begraben und der mann von marina
litwinenko alexander
der ehemalige russische agent war
übergelaufen und wurde aus rache und zur
abschreckung 2006 von seinen eigenen ex
kollegen mit polonium vergiftet schon
damals so marina war die naivität des
westens gegenüber putin verhängnisvoll
als mein mann ins krankenhaus gebracht
wurde und wir versuchten zu beweisen
dass er vergiftet worden war konnten die
leute es nicht glauben die ärzte haben
ihn nicht mal darauf hin getestet erst
als er zehn tage später klare zeichen
von radioaktiver strahlung aufwies sie
hatten vorher einfach nicht geglaubt
dass jemand mitten in london vergiftet
werden kann das ist genau das was jetzt
auch passiert ist die leute konnten
nicht glauben dass jemand der vielleicht
ein bisschen exzessiv ist aber wie ein
europäischer politiker aussieht zum
diktator geworden ist
konnten und wollten es nicht glauben
denn das große geld lockte viele nicht
nur die briten die europäer wollten die
skrupellosigkeit putins bis zum 24
februar nicht sehen jetzt sind die
russen fassungslos dass die ukraine doch
so anders ticken als sie meint marina
den russen ging es immer nur ums geld
jeder der ihnen in die quere kam beim
geld verdienen musste umgelegt werden so
wie mein mann und jetzt mit der ukraine
ist es so dass das ein russland sehr
verwandt des landes die menschen sind
sich ähnlich wie putin nennt sie selbst
ein bruder volk sie haben sogar dieselbe
religion aber diese leute beweisen jetzt
dass es ihnen um die freiheit hat
auch putins reiche freunde erleben eine
zäsur wenn ihre bislang grenzenlose
freiheit und setzt in london langsam zu
ende geht